[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Dylan how we doing hey I uh just had a
quick question for you both uh I'm
assuming John you'll be able to answer
this a little better but you might J is
way smarter than me well well we'll see
how it goes um so it would seem that my
mom is boycotting my rehearsal and my
rehearsal dinner because I changed
uh a small
plan I don't know I might be able to
answer this one cuz I know about that
dude I'm I'm laughing with you man like
so what what' you do Richard what you
what did you change that was so bad so
I'll run it quick so um you know back
months ago when we gave them the
opportunity to uh kind of plan the
dinner it's not what we wanted
originally we told him you know we just
wanted to have pizza and go back to the
Airbnb and just have a good time with
the bridal party well my mom absolutely
insisted on um paying for this and
making you know a big dinner we go out
and all this and that and obviously you
know listening to you guys like trying
to save as much money as possible but uh
she wasn't on board with that um and you
know I gave her the opportunity for
months and months and months and a few
days ago I talked to her and told her
I'm like Hey we're really thinking about
switching back to our original plan and
I was like I'll give you a few days to
uh figure it out well I just waited one
day and I was like you know what I
should do what I really want to do with
my special day you know and my of course
my fiance's too but um and I decided I'm
like hey this is what we're going to do
instead um I I didn't see this coming I
didn't see this coming but I want to
lean on you a little bit and you push
back okay of course why would you take
this from your mom it's like a dinner
that she's paying
for be well just because it's originally
not what we wanted and she I should add
to this too she started inviting a bunch
of people that we didn't want there
there it is there we go okay that too
lead with that brother lead lead with
that cuz that that changed that was that
wasn't the biggest issue I don't think
is that she didn't really respect that
we originally wanted to do something
else that's how I took it Dylan is there
strings attached to this as in as in I'm
doing this for you so somewhere down the
line there's going to be an expectation
of something I want from
you you know there I I'm not going to go
as far as but it's
not oh I know I know about
it um all right so here's here's the
deal this is as as heartbreaking and
complicated as this is this is very very
simple you made a grown-up
choice and with all grown-up choices
there always comes grown-up consequences
to those choices
unfortunately your mom is choosing to
act like a child and I mean that with
all due respect I don't like talking
about people's masas but here we are oh
I've said it a few times right so one of
the hardest things I think any of us
will experience is when somebody we love
opts out of relationship with us because
they're choosing to be immature because
they are making our whatever how we're
raising our kid what school our kid goes
to our choice of diet our whatever you
want to say they make our lives about
them yeah and she is choosing to not be
in relationship with you and your wife
during your big
day and that just hurts and so it's a
both end I want you to spend time even
just for a few minutes saying like this
sucks me I don't want my mom in my
wedding I hate that she's acting like
this and you and I both know she acts
like this on other things too this isn't
isolated right no not at all awesome an
can I add something of course of course
she's going to come to your
dinner well I think she hoping I'm
hoping so I would write her a letter so
bad hey here I would write her a letter
that she can go back to over and over
and over
again and say we really it would mean
the world to us that you come I know
that you you wanted a big a big thing
and I'm so grateful that you're honoring
us for this one we really want you here
yeah I mean the thing is that uh I mean
she won't even come to the rehearsal
which I which is the worst part to me
I'm okay if she didn't want to come to
the dinner saying that she's saying that
and I don't know her so I may be totally
off Bas I think that this is her lastage
effort to get her away on this and my I
would probably be willing to
put couple I put some chips on the table
on this that she's going to end up there
I don't think she's going to miss her
son's major days over this now maybe I
don't know her and and I'm completely
wrong but uh something tells me that
when the rubber hits the road she's
going to be there what about your old
man have you talked to him about it yeah
I actually spoke to him today and he
just initially you know his first time
also keep in mind my my mother won't
talk to me at all she will not talk to
me of course well you ruined her life
jerk oh you know yeah absolutely ripping
her heart out but I did speak to my dad
this morning and he was saying that she
just feels hurt and that it doesn't have
anything to do with the dinner which I
don't believe because this kind of stuff
has happened before which she doesn't
get her way in this which I don't
believe but uh well he's probably been
covering her for her for a long time too
right
oh of course yeah I mean obviously he
has to take her side in most cases and I
don't blame him but yeah no I mean yeah
no I spoke to him so if she will talk to
you the best the best I can tell you is
what I would do in your situation and
that would be I would write a letter and
I would do my best to deliver it by hand
if you all in the same if you all live
in the same Community put it in her
mailbox by hand I was at her house
yesterday okay and let her have
something cuz listen if you call her if
you text her she is going to hear that
one time time in her through her filter
of Dylan is trying to ruin my life yeah
and Dylan's going to embarrass me
because I'm in charge of the dinner and
everyone's going to ask me why I just
did pizza and it's all about her but if
you write it down people can go back to
the letter and back to it and back to it
and sometimes not always but sometimes
that truth has a way of distilling
itself down and she can rest in he wants
me there him and his wife are just
trying to do things a little bit
differently it's not about me Etc and
you hope that's the case but we all have
that's what I'm hoping but great idea
truth and tell your dad we really really
want both of y'all there oh I I told him
that I told him that this morning when I
spoke to him I'm like if the worst case
scenario happens I'm like please dad be
at my wedding yes like at the very least
like yeah so yeah it's pretty crazy I
hate it for you I hate it for you I
appreciate it thank you though but yeah
that was pretty much it I appreciate you
guys yeah I don't get to it's not every
day I get to talk to somebody who just
willy-nilly rips his mom's heart out
right J dude look when it comes to these
weddings it's like that like if I had
done what all the parents had wanted I
would have been married in a different
state I would have been got I would have
gotten married on a different date I
would have gotten married you know in a
different dress like they all have their
preferences but at the end of the day it
is your your ADV it's your day thing and
sometimes it's just a dinner do the
dinner but if it is that big of a deal
you may a grownup choice and that comes
with grownup consequences that's right